m
[Musique]
merci
c'est toujours un bonheur de pouvoir
passer un bonheur si ce dernier
recherche vous alors moi je vais vous
dire tous les samedis soirs je vous jure
que c'est vrai tous mes copains rappelé
pour parler de la tenue de jennifer
s'était il parlait même pas de
l'émission qui adore se loupe moi
franchement jennifer venez on va partir
sur un garçon a look comme ça aussi on
n'espérait pas moi c'est vrai mais ça va
pas du tout aimé bleuse lui je peux
faire cette hausse touche en effet les
et là il me dit d'aller prendre cassante
n'ont pas mis de la crème
samian washing ou yachir et claude
jennifer non mais je vous le dis c'est
un truc de ouf
allez la voir il ya un nouveau single
qui est sorti pour ceux qui n'en garde
je vous montrerai comment ça se danse
si vous êtes chez vous tranquillement
allez
si tu es
[Musique]
jamais tu délires capillaires je
resterai quelques-uns ah oui c'est vrai
j'ai été rousse vénitienne pendant trois
jours il n'y a pas longtemps sur sur la
vie de ma mère ouais c'est mon fantasme
ou blonde platine mais je suis resté
deux jours comme ça t'as pas kiffer n'a
pas jean michel maire jean michel maire
pour la vivre une nuit
jamais je n'ai pas la personne que je
vois à la télé parfois mais donc du coup
pour l'heure que vous allez dire quoique
au nom également des faussaires chômage
ça veut dire des concerts à las vegas à
une crise quelqu'un est allé chômage
nous explique cette partie là du corps
ne bouge pas cette partie là nous ça se
passe
si tu es
non
jennifer si tu me prends qu'elle doit
essayer vous sur le bonheur que j'ai une
très très belle surprise quand est ce
que vous savez est ce que vous savez
qu'ils sont océane brunel maylis et
anaïs ce sont des gens qui comptent
beaucoup pour vous dire ni faire
d'accord est ce que vous savez de qui il
s'agit vous ne les connaissez pas
vraiment il rêvait de vous voir en vrai
son parti d'une association qui nous
tient énormément à coeur n'en touche pas
à mon poste et dont vous êtes la
marraine elle refit le refuge exactement
merci de les accueillir ils sont venus
avec olivier serge et aurélie qui sont
bénévoles auront plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
abandonner la darse de l'épaule sinon
alors maintenant je suis un éventail de
danses tu vas apprendre à les connaître
jennifer chorégraphe mais c'est un
bordel aulas et le chorégraphe c'est
curieux non
[Musique]